the low Tech of a balloon didn't stand a
chance against the high-tech of American
jet fighters immediately after the shoot
down defense secretary Lloyd Austin
tried to call his Chinese counterpart to
explain I put in a request for a call
and uh and they did not accept that
request Austin told CBS News the Navy
has recovered most of the balloon and is
getting ready to bring up the pieces of
the cameras and antennas it was carrying
we've mapped out the debris field and
now we'll go through
detailed efforts to recover the debris
that's on the ocean floor Austin says
the balloon's route took it past
ballistic missile fields and the B2
stealth bomber base all of our strategic
assets we were made sure that uh we were
buttoned down and movement was limited
and Communications were were
limited so that we didn't expose any
capability unnecessarily but a strategic
assets you mean the the nuclear force